The price of just about everything has gone up over the past year.
Bananas will cost you six percent more on average.
Milk, 15% and eggs are 25% more expensive.
It's all part of rising inflation,...
...which hit 8.5% in March, the highest in 40 years.
Why is inflation happening?
It all goes back to supply and demand.
The price of something is a balancing act between these two factors.
Let's take beef, for example.
When COVID struck, meat production slowed dramatically...
...as farmers had to scale their operations.
Transportation costs and a labor shortage...
...has made it even harder to produce beef,...
...reducing supply and raising the price of a pound of steak...
...more than 18%.
The Federal Reserve has started using its main tool to combat inflation,...
...raising interest rates.
Which can reduce demand and bring back the economy into balance.